[Music]
almost all good native mobile apps have
one thing in common and that's a
high-quality loading page when you enter
the app for the first time in this
episode I'm going to show you how to
build your own high-quality splash
graphics with ionic we're going to make
sure the graphics and the animation look
good on both iOS and Android and I'm
going to take a different approach than
other tutorials out there have taken
most importantly I want to show you how
to avoid this ugly white page if you're
using animations in your splash page hit
subscribe if you're new and follow along
with the source code at angular firebase
comm I am starting out from a brand new
ionic app and using the side menu
starter template before we do anything
with animation I first want to show you
how to generate an app icon and static
splash page from the command line start
by going into the resources directory
and delete the icon and splash PNG files
then you'll need to generate your own
graphics and something like Photoshop or
sketch the app icon needs to be at least
a thousand 24 pixels and the splash page
needs to be at least 2732 pixels
once you have those created you can just
go ahead and save them back in the
resources directory with the same name
splash and icon from there we can
generate all of the icons we need for
every single device on a given platform
all you need to do is run I on it
Cordova resources from the command line
and it's going to do everything else for
you this takes your source images and
resizes them so they look good on the
iPad iPhone and other mobile devices you
can see the results by going under the
platform directory under resources and
looking at all the generated graphics if
you open your app on a native emulator
you should see the custom graphic as
well as the custom splash screen that
looks pretty cool and is probably enough
for most apps but I still want to show
you how to take things a step further by
adding your own custom animation the
easiest strategy in my opinion is to use
a CSS animation but you could also use
JavaScript here as well to keep things
simple I'm going to use a pre-built
open source animation but you could
customize this in any way that you want
you can control the behavior of the
splash screen in your config dot XML
file
Apache Cordova has a number of different
preferences or options that you
configure to control the way the splash
screen behaves on different platforms I
recommend checking out the Cordova
documentation just to get an idea of
what each one of these preferences will
do one strategy that I've seen used is
to set the show splash screen option to
false that will completely prevent the
static image we created earlier from
being displayed that might seem like
what we want and it does kind of work
but it does have one major problem it
causes this white screen to appear
briefly when the app is launched which
might last for a second or two and kind
of ruins the intro animation I think a
better approach is to fade in from your
static graphic in a way that looks
seamless for the end user you can do
that by simply matching the background
from your static image to the actual CSS
that you use for the animation but we
still want to close that static graphic
as soon as possible
so we're going to make a few changes to
our config I'm going to set the splash
screen delay to 10 seconds which is way
longer than we actually need but we're
going to close it as soon as we can once
the platform is ready so make sure to
set a screen delay make sure that the
auto-hide is set to false and that the
show splash screen is set to true then
we can hide it when the app is
initialized which I onyx already going
to do by default but just in case go
into the app component and make sure
you're hiding the splash screen when the
app is initialized now from the same
component we'll go ahead and import
timer from rxjs then we'll define a
property on this component called show
splash which is set to true by default
that will control the visibility of the
animation and then back down in the
initialize app method we'll set the
timer and set it to false after 3,000
milliseconds all we have to do to start
the timer is subscribe to it and it will
execute this code when the time runs out
now let's open the HTML for the app
component basically all we're creating
here is an overlay that's going to cover
the screen until this show splash
variable is set to false I'm just
showing a basic loading spinner here but
you could add your own custom complex
SVG animation inside this element at
this point we just need to round it out
with some CSS I'm just going to copy and
paste this animation from spin kit then
I'm going to write my own class to make
it behave like an overlay it has a
position of absolute with a width and
height
% then a z-index with a large number
just so it's displayed on top of other
elements then we can use flexbox to
ensure that it's responsive and displays
the loading spinner directly in the
center of the screen on any device and
lastly I'll give it a background color
to match our static graphic that we
created in the first part then we can
just paste in our spin kit code and we
should be good to go if we pull the app
up on iPhone X we should get the initial
static image and then loading spinner
right after that I'm going to go ahead
and wrap up there if this video helped
you please like and subscribe and if
you're serious about building native
apps with ionic I have a full course
specifically for native development that
should be out in the next couple weeks
if you're a pro member you'll get access
for free in addition to a whole bunch of
other exclusive resources thanks for
watching and I'll see you soon